Rusia, Putin, Moscú.
No hay duda posible, uno de los elementos
más controvertidos de Donald Trump está
siendo su aparente fascinación por Rusia
y su carismático líder, Vladimir Putin.
Insinuaciones, mensajes de apoyo y la elección
de altos cargos muy cercanos al Kremlin.
La pregunta es ¿Está Trump intentando seducir
al oso ruso?
O, como dicen algunos, ¿hay algo sospechoso
en esta relación?
Lo cierto es que la apuesta de Trump por Rusia
podría tener una explicación: según cada
vez más analistas, los asesores del nuevo
inquilino del Despacho Oval quieren dejar
su huella emulando el gran éxito político
que Richard Nixon y Henry Kissinger tuvieron
con China.
NIXON SEDUCE A LA CHINA DE MAO
El 21 de febrero de 1972 se produjo uno de
los acontecimientos más importantes de las
últimas décadas.
Ese día, Richard Nixon llegó a Pekín.
Fue la primera visita de un Presidente de
Estados Unidos a la China Comunista.
UN GRAN PASO PARA NIXON, UN DESCONOCIDO PASO
PARA LA HUMANIDAD
Como si de unos juegos olímpicos o un gran
espectáculo se tratara, todo el viaje fue
ampliamente retransmitido por TV.
Por este motivo millones de personas contuvieron
el aliento mientras presenciaban a través
de sus pantallas como Richard Nixón bajaba
las escaleras del Air Force One y ponía su
primer pie en la Capital de Mao.
Pero, antes de nada, retrocedamos un poquito
más para ver qué implicaciones tuvo esta
visita ¿Cuáles eran sus objetivos?
¿Cómo fue posible?
Vayamos hasta el 1 de octubre de 1949, ese
día se proclamó la República Popular China,
los comunistas liderados por Mao habían ganado
la guerra por el poder de China.
La animadversión del nuevo régimen chino
hacia Washington era total.
De hecho, tan solo un año después, las tropas
del ejército chino intervinieron en la Guerra
de Corea para apoyar al régimen de Pyongyang,
enfrentándose así, cara a cara, con el ejército
de Estados Unidos.
Por supuesto tras esta lucha a cara de perro
que supuso la muerte de miles de soldados
en ambos bandos, desapareció cualquier intención
de establecer relaciones diplomáticas.
Casi podemos decir que desde ese momento chinos
y estadounidenses se habían declarado odio
eterno.
Mientras tanto, las relaciones de Pekín con
Moscú, ya os podéis imaginar, eran muy diferentes.
Es verdad que Mao nunca se había llevado
bien con los líderes soviéticos, que de
hecho habían apoyado a otras personas para
liderar el Partido Comunista Chino.
Sin embargo, a pesar de tener muchas diferencias,
tras la proclamación de la República Popular
China, la alianza era casi inevitable:
Por un lado, la Unión Soviética tenía la
imperiosa necesidad de controlar o al menos
tratar de influenciar a la otra gran potencia
comunista.
Por el otro, la China de Mao necesitaba desesperadamente
la ayuda de la URSS: ayuda económica, tecnológica
y militar.
La ayuda fue de tal magnitud que entre 1954
y 1959 la Unión Soviética se gastó en China
más del 7% de todos los recursos del gobierno
en esos años.
Hay quienes dicen que fue la mayor Transferencia
de tecnología de la historia del mundo.
A pesar de todo ello, poco a poco las diferencias
políticas sobre prácticamente todos los
grandes temas fueron apareciendo y erosionando
esa alianza hasta llegar a la ruptura total.
La tensión crecía y crecía y si en 1967
la embajada de la Unión Soviética en Pekín
fue asaltada, en 1969 se produjo el primer
gran choque armado.
El 2 de marzo de 1969 tropas del ejército
popular de la Unión Soviética trato de invadir
la isla de Zhenbao, situada en el río Ussuri
que durante gran parte de su recorrido hace
de frontera entre China y Rusia, entonces
la Unión Soviética.
La invasión fue repelida con gran número
de bajas en el ejército chino, pero unos
días después los s oviéticos respondieron
bombardeando a las tropas chinas en la isla.
El conflicto no fue más allá, pero durante
unos días se temió incluso que este diese
lugar a una guerra abierta a gran escala.
Moscú llegó a plantear el envío de tropas
del Pacto de Varsovia, a lo que se opuso Rumanía.
E incluso, fijaros, se dice que, ante el rumor
de un ataque nuclear disuasorio, Nixon se
comunicó con Moscú para dejarles claro que
Estados Unidos no aceptaría bajo ningún
concepto esa posibilidad.
“El enemigo de mi enemigo, es mi amigo”.
Así que dicho y hecho, se pusieron manos
a la obra, y en dos años Nixon estaba en
Pekín.
Las relaciones entre Estados Unidos y China
avanzaron lentamente, de hecho, no fue hasta
1979 con Jimmy Carter en la Casa Blanca cuando
se establecieron relaciones plenas, pero lo
cierto es que el viaje de Nixon dio paso a
una época de entendimiento cuyos resultados
son incuestionables:
Si en 1972 el comercio bilateral no llegaba
ni con mucho a los 1.000 millones de dólares,
hoy se aproxima a los 600.000 millones, las
relaciones han sido relativamente cordiales
y EEUU se aseguró un aliado contra la Unión
Soviética en plena guerra fría.
Pues bien, según muchos analistas eso es
precisamente lo que persigue hoy Trump, reeditar
la estrategia de Nixon y Kissinger solo que
cambiando a Pekín por Moscú.
Eso explicaría la inclinación obscenamente
pro-rusa de Donald.
Sin embargo, hoy las cosas son muy diferentes
a 1969.
EL IDILIO ENTRE CHINA Y RUSIA
Desde finales de la década de los 80 las
relaciones entre China y Rusia fueron mejorando
poco a poco, un tratado por aquí, un acuerdo
por allá…
Pero la llegada al poder de Xi Jinping en
2012 lo cambió todo.
Desde entonces la relación entre ambas potencias
ha avanzado a toda velocidad.
Fijaros qué decía en 2016 uno de los pesos
pesados del gobierno chino:
“La profundidad y el alcance de coordinación
entre ambos países no tiene precedentes”.
Yang Jiechi.
Y es que al parecer Xi Jinping y Vladimir
Putin han cuajado buenas relaciones personales,
pero sobre todo Pekín ha visto la posibilidad
de ganar muchos puntos en su carrera por ganar
una influencia internacional acorde a su posición
económica.
Una alianza entre China y Rusia sería muy
poderosa desde cualquier punto de vista.
De momento hoy los dos países cooperan como
nunca antes: en 2016 Rusia se convirtió en
el primer suministrador de petróleo de China,
un petróleo que, además, amigos de VisualPolitik,
llega por tierra lo que es muy importante
para China, porque en caso de conflicto, Estados
Unidos no podría bloquearlo, algo que sí
podría hacer a día de hoy con los suministros
por vía marítima.
Además, los dos países han comenzado a realizar
asiduamente ejercicios militares conjuntos,
han impulsado los vínculos económicos y
tecnológicos y se han puesto de acuerdo para
sacar adelante infraestructuras que conecten
sus dos países.
¿Queréis tres ejemplos de todo ello?
Pues atentos a estos ejemplos, solo 3 ejemplos:
Primero, los ejercicios militares:
“China y Rusia acorazan su alianza con maniobras
en el mar de China Meridional” La Vanguardia
Segundo, los vínculos económicos:
“China y Rusia se alían para 'destrozar'
el duopolio aeronáutico de Boeing y Airbus”
El Economista.
Y tercero, las infraestructuras.
A este respecto que mejor muestra que esta:
¡Tras 28 años!
¿Eso es una prueba de amor, no os parece?
Pero aquí no acaba todo, por si fuese poco
ambos países han firmado importantes acuerdos
militares por los que China se va a gastar
miles de millones en adquirir algunas de los
equipos más modernos del ejército ruso,
como por ejemplo los sistemas de misiles tierra-aire
S-400 o la joya del ejército popular, el
caza Su-35.
Aquí podéis ver esta preciosidad.
Y junto a todo ello, muchos acuerdos económicos,
monetarios, políticos, vamos que EEUU tiene
motivos para estar preocupado.
Sobre todo si tenemos en cuenta que los intereses
de ambos países parecen estar bien alineados
contra un enemigo común: Washington.
AMENAZAS AL AMOR CHINO-RUSO
Pero un momento antes de echarnos a temblar
ante el tándem chino-ruso; no todo es de
color de rosas.
Puede que ambas potencias hayan acercado posturas,
pero aún son muchos los elementos que les
separan o al menos los que pueden debilitar
esta unidad:
China quiere hacer valer su relevancia económica
en términos políticos y eso implica por
ejemplo convertirse en el líder de Asia Central.
Su plan sobre la ruta de la seda que vimos
en este pasado vídeo sigue esa línea.
Por supuesto, de esto Moscú no quiere oír
ni hablar, en su opinión los espacios soviéticos
tienen que quedar bajo la influencia exclusiva
de Moscú.
Por otro lado, las relaciones económicas
también plantean divisiones: Para Rusia existe
un claro desequilibrio, en los últimos años
se han convertido en un suministrador de recursos
naturales para China mientras que este país
inunda el mercado ruso de bienes manufacturados
y de mayor valor.
Por el lado chino, su posición respecto al
comercio internacional y el modelo económico
es mucho más pragmática: los chinos quieren
ganar dinero, saben que para ellos abrirse
al mundo es bueno, una visión que Moscú
no comparte.
Y luego está también el problema con algunos
socios rusos como la India, de la cual es
el mayor proveedor de armas, algo que no hace
especial gracia en Pekín.
Vamos, que, aunque ambos países acerquen
posturas y se apoyen mutuamente contra EEUU
no esperemos de ellos una relación excesivamente
sólida.
Al fin y al cabo, tarde o temprano China querrá
ser el líder en la relación, y eso difícilmente
lo aceptará Moscú.
¿ES FACTIBLE EL PLAN DE TRUMP?
La verdad, a día de hoy el plan de Trump
de reeditar la estrategia Nixon no parece
muy factible.
Es verdad que Trump ve en China a su principal
enemigo:
Pero a pesar de ello, si quiere ganarse
el apoyo de Moscú tendría que hacer concesiones
que difícilmente se aceptarían en Washington:
eliminación de Sanciones, cesión en Ucrania
y en Siria, fin del escudo antimisiles entre
otras muchas.
Putin puede ser exigente.
Y aunque lo lograse, no está claro que Rusia
le sirviese de mucho para la contención del
gigante asiático.
Es por ello que Obama prefirió apostar por
rodear al gigante chino llegando a acuerdos
con sus vecinos: India, Vietnam, Malasia…
y en esta estrategia el TPP jugaba un papel
clave, y digo tumbaba porque como sabrás
fue una de las primeras cosas que Trump tumbó
al llegar a la Casa Blanca..
¿No suena muy coherente, ¿verdad?
Por cierto, si queréis saber más sobre la
política exterior de Obama no os perdáis
este vídeo
Bueno, ¿Tu qué opinas?
¿Consolidarán Rusia y China una super alianza
contra EEUU?
¿Logrará Trump reeditar el acuerdo de Nixon
pero cambiando Pekín por Moscú?
Espero vuestras respuestas y si os ha gustado
el vídeo dadle al botón de like.
Os esperamos también en Twitter y Facebook.
Y por supuesto no os olvidéis del hermano
pequeño de VisualPolitik: VisualPolitik en
inglés.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.